حقيقة أننا رأينا الرقم على
سائقي سيارات الأجرة في مختبر هوفر
، لكنني في الحقيقة عبارة عن علم أحمر ، وأوبر يجعل
عمالهم يلعبون لعبة الروليت الروسية
مع حياة العديد من العائلات
وأفراد الجمهور ،
وهذا خطأ جوهري مثل
عدد حالات الإصابة بالفيروس التاجي يرتفع في جميع أنحاء العالم ،
الأطفال العمال مثل السعاة أو سائقي سيارات
الأجرة معرضون للخطر بشكل خاص
أولاً ، صحتهم ما زلنا
نحاول التغلب على انتشار هذا الفيروس بالضبط ،
لكننا رأينا بوضوح
عددًا من سائقي سيارات الأجرة يصابون
بواحد  من الأشياء التي نعرفها أن
ملامسة القطرات أمر مهم ، ما تناوله مع
القهوة التي تطلقها قطرات صغيرة
يتلامس الناس مع تلك
القطرات بأيديهم
ثم يلامسون وجههم ،
وهذا هو نمط انتقال
الوعي فقط أكثر عرضة للإفراج عنه في
معظم الآخرين.  أفراد من الجمهور
لمجرد قضاء يومي بالكامل مع
غرباء على مقربة شديدة
دون أي
بروتينات مهمة  ctions ولكن ليس
الاتصال مع الأشخاص فقط هو الذي يعرضهم
للخطر بشكل فريد ، لا يحصل العمال الكبار على
مزايا كاملة مثل الموظفين بدوام كامل ،
أشياء مثل الرعاية الصحية المدعومة وإجازة
مدفوعة الأجر ، وهذا هو السبب في قيام ألفا
وأعضاء آخرين في المجموعة بالعمل.
تحاول إجبار شركات
مثل lyft uber doordash Amazon
وغيرها على منحهم مزايا كاملة عندما
لا يحصل الأشخاص على أيام مرضية مدفوعة الأجر ، فهذا يعني
أنهم لا يعتنون بأنفسهم ،
فهذا يعني أنهم يؤجلون الذهاب إلى
الأطباء حتى ينتهي بهم الأمر بالعمل بدلاً
من  البقاء في المنزل إذا لم أعمل ،
لا يمكنني دفع فواتيري الآن بعد شهور
من هذه الأزمة الصحية الدولية
، حيث بدأت الشركات في تغيير
سياساتها ، تقدم كل من uber و lyft
الآن مدفوعات للسائقين الذين تم
تشخيص إصابتهم بفيروس كورونا أو تم
يقول مسؤولو الصحة العامة في الحجر الصحي ، أوبر ، إنه بدأ بالفعل في
دفع بعض السائقين ، ولكن في الوقت الحالي مع
عدم توفر الاختبارات بسهولة ،
تحصل في الواقع على تشخيص
يمكن أن يكون فيروس كورونا صعبًا إن لم يكن
مستحيلًا ، علاوة على ذلك ،
لم تقل الشركات كم
ستدفع
للسائقين الذين ثبتت إصابتهم أو يخضعون
للحجر الصحي عندما يسعل الناس إذا
سعلوا النوافذ في
الخلف قليلاً  قليلًا ولطيفًا منكم يدركون
الهواء حول السيارة
لن أتجول هنا مع قناع
لإخافة الناس بسبب المطر
فيروس كورونا هانكس ليس أكثر ترويعًا من أي شيء
آخر قد تتعرض له لرومو
ليس الفيروس الوحيد  يمكن أن يصيبك بالمرض
من الأشخاص الآخرين ، لذا فأنا قلق بشأن
كل فيروس وأنا شديد الحذر ،
لذا فأنت تعلم أن لديّ القليل من
الكحول الذي يحتوي على 91 كحولًا كما تعلمون أنه يقتل كل شيء
يقتل كل شيء في معمل كيميائي ،
وسوف يقتل كل شيء فيه  تشجع هذه السيارة كلاً من
uber و lyft
سائقيهم الآن على تطهير السيارات
بانتظام وتقدم الشركتان
الإمدادات لهم للقيام بذلك ولكن
بالنسبة لعامل الحفلة الذي يقوم بتنظيف سياراتهم
، فإن الوقت والوقت يساوي المال الذي
أعيش بدونه  شبكة أمان كنتيجة لذلك
تبدأ يومك وتعتقد
أنك اليوم سيكون اليوم الذي
يحدث فيه شيء سيء وستخرج
حياتي المالية تمامًا عن مسارها